>> ALL RIGHT.
BOTH OF YOU PLEASE STAY WITH ME.
KAITLAN COLLINS IS WITH US NOW
WITH SOME MORE ON THIS
REPORTING, AND KAITLAN,
OBVIOUSLY A VERY SIGNIFICANT
HEADLINE THAT YOU ARE BREAKING.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
>> YEAH, THIS IS INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT, AND OF COURSE WE
SHOULD NOTE THAT WHEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CONFIRMED THAT, YES,
THIS RAID DID HAPPEN ON HIS
MAR-A-LAGO RESORT IN PALM BEACH,
HE DID NOT SPECIFY WHY EXACTLY
THIS RAID HAPPENED, SO WE ARE
STILL TRYING TO CONFIRM THAT.
OF COURSE I KNOW YOU MENTIONED
THE MISSING DOCUMENTS FROM THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT.
SO THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
I WILL NOTE THAT IN THIS
STATEMENT WHERE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CONFIRMED TO ME THAT,
YES, FBI AGENTS DID CONDUCT A
RAID AT MAR-A-LAGO TODAY, HE
SAID IT WAS A LARGE NUMBER OF
FBI -- A LARGE GROUP OF FBI
AGENTS.
HE SAYS THAT HE BELIEVES THIS IS
A POLITICAL -- POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED EVENT THAT HAPPENED,
THE SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO.
OF COURSE WE'RE WAITING TO HEAR
FROM AUTHORITIES WHY THEY
CONDUCTED THIS SEARCH, HOW THEY
GOT THIS SEARCH WARRANT, AND OF
COURSE WHAT THE REASON IS BEHIND
IT.
I WILL NOTE, HE DOES GIVE ONE
DETAIL IN HERE THAT IS NOTABLE.
HE SAYS, QUOTE, ERIN, I'M GOING
TO READ THIS NOW.
SUCH AN ASSAULT COULD ONLY TAKE
PLACE IN BROKEN THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES.
SADLY AMERICA HAS NOW BECOME ONE
OF THOSE COUNTRIES.
HE SAYS, QUOTE, THEY EVEN BROKE
INTO MY SAFE.
NOW, ERIN, HE DOES NOT SAY WHAT
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR, WHAT THEY
WANTED TO GET IF THEY TOOK
ANYTHING FROM THAT SAFE, BUT IT
IS NOTABLE, HE SAYS, THEY DID
EVEN BREAK INTO HIS SAFE.
AND THIS STATEMENT, I SHOULD
NOTE WHEN HE DOES NOT SAY WHAT
THE REASON IS FOR THIS RAID, HE
DOES REFERENCE HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAILS.
OF COURSE THAT HAS LONG BEEN AN
OBSESSION OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S.
HE SAID NOTHING HAPPENED TO HER
TO HOLD HER ACCOUNTABLE, TALKING
ABOUT WHAT SHE TOOK TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THAT COULD BE AN INDICATION TH